for the dodgers to start this game
hearththrowing right-hander bruce
darkraderol he is 0.2 the 3.24 era in 17
games all out of the bullpen swinging a
miss strike three and that's how the
game begins with a swinging strikeout of
george springer
gets bregman to swing and miss and he
strikes out on three pitches two up two
down in the top half of the first inning
with michael brantley making his way to
the plate one-one from gradual
is served into the opposite field and
that's how you straighten out 101 miles
an hour i mean the epitome of a great
hitter a little stretch scratterell set
at the belt kicks delivers home swinging
a miss strike three so three strikeouts
and a base hit one man left and the
bazooka shoots them down in the first
inning against a guy who wore a dodger
uniform
and did so very successfully over a
three-year span the six-time all-star
six-time goal glover zach grinky it's
0-2 to mookie betts leading off the home
half of the first and bets rolls over a
ground ball for correa who made the play
while that ball was getting past him and
a dandy for carlos correa the former
number one pick
two up two down and aj pollock the
batter pollock waits for it and he
drives it deep to left field this ball
back this ball gone into the bullpen
a home run for aj pollock his tenth of
the season and the dodgers jump in front
one to nothing two two swing and a miss
got him on a big curve ball and muncie
goes down on strikes first k for grinky
that ends the inning bruce dark
graderell started for the dodgers first
major league start tonight he got
through the side without incident and
now it's going to be a series of
relievers used by l.a here's chris
taylor bunting and that's a good one
bregman bare hands he won't have a play
pitch on the way and that's a ground
ball right side right at toro throws a
second for one correa the gun to first
base and grinky with the stretch and
able to get the out grinky was lying on
his stomach when he fielded that throw
and the inning draws to a close what a
double play score that 3-6-1 as rookie
left-hander victor gonzalez takes over
this inning fastball slider and he hits
this one hard down the left field line
that's going to be a fair ball and
that's going to hop into the seats and
clank off somebody's head one of those
cutouts and it's a stand up double for
bregman with michael brantley a good
hitter at the plate pitch swung on
ground ball to the right side charging
from the outfield grasses taylor strong
thrower first gets him and they strand
bregman and leave the tying run on after
two and a half innings at dodgers
stadium it's the dodgers one astros
nothing without nobody on that's having
a another great year a really good year
in his first campaign with the dodgers
here's the pitch slow curve ball and he
pops this one into left field brantley
goes back a couple steps now back to
right where he was standing to begin
with and makes the catch for out number
two here's the pitch change up got him
strike three his grinky had him way out
in front and that's the first strike out
of the ball game for grinky and we've
got three in the foot here's redick he
flew out to deep right field as last
time up catcher sits outside now
here's the pitch swing and a miss had
him out front of another breaking pitch
victor settled the hill the 2-2 pitch
he bounced at the plate check swing did
he go they'll appeal down to mark
ripager at first base he says he went
and that's a strikeout a 1-2-3 inning
for victor gonzalez and he punches out
two
and the dodgers now have set up shop
second and third and nobody out for jack
peterson
ground ball hit to the right side
fielded by mayfield looks the runner
back and throws out peterson and that is
out number one boy a beautiful change up
about shin high and that's why he got
the ground ball perfect now one out and
[ __ ] hernandez will try to get bellinger
in sharply hit through the hole on the
left side it scores bellinger here's
taylor around to score and it's
three-nothing los angeles so now it's
the top of the order mookie batsuzo for
two so far and tonight he swings and
hits a high drive to right center field
and deep going back springer to the
track springer to the wall he leaps it's
gone five nothing dodgers mookie bets
with his 15th home run of the season in
his third career home run off of zach
grenky in just five advance against it
george springer who's over two with a
strikeout and a ground out hit in the
air by springer center field carries
pretty deep it sends back hernandez at
the wall looking up see you later george
springer goes deep and the astros are on
the board it's 5-1 la springer with his
ninth home run of the year oh it's woods
good traffic this is the most traffic in
any one inning tonight they've not had
more than one man on in any inning 3-2
pitch is popped up shallow right
taylor pointing to it in the sky mookie
betts
picks it out of the twilight sky and
grabs it for the second out of the unit
mayfield swings and misses he strikes
out as woody got him with a 92 mile an
hour sinker so nothing across from the
top of the seventh for the astros they
get a hit leave two
runners at second and third with two gun
chris taylor the batter taylor hits one
high and deep to left field this ball
back this ball gone a three-run home run
for chris taylor eight to one